[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON WANJALA: Hello, everyone.
I'm Aaron Wanjala, and I'm
very excited to be here at IO
talking to you.
I'm a Java developer advocate
here at Google Cloud,
but before joining Google,
I spent several years
as a dev building, shipping, and
maintaining Spring and Angular
apps.
As a Java developer
advocate, it's
my job to sit between Google
Cloud and you, the Java dev
community, in order to
help our products to be
as useful as possible to you.
That could mean
coming to conferences
and doing workshops like
this, contributing to projects
directly, or just
hearing you folks out
and bringing your
feedback to product teams.
That's why I'm
excited to be here.
I get to share what I hope
is some useful information
with you, and most
importantly, invite
you to start a conversation.
So if you have any
feedback on this workshop
or Google Cloud's
projects, in general,
I'm available on Twitter.
DMs are open.
Feel free to reach out.
In today's workshop,
we'll be focusing
on the Spring Native project.
We'll start by explaining what
it is and talking about some
of its recent milestones.
After that, we'll go
over some good use
cases for Spring Native
apps, and finally, we'll
work through
implementing it together.
So without further ado,
what is Spring Native?
Simply put, Spring
Native is a project
to make it easier for developers
to compile their Spring
applications into
native executables.
Running your applications
as native executables,
rather than on the JVM
means smaller artifacts,
faster startup times, and lower
memory usage, all of which
allows you to get more work done
with resources that you already
have.
We'll get into the details of
why that is in just a moment.
Spring Native makes
use of several concepts
and technologies to
make this happen,
including ahead-of-time
compilation and GraalVM.
We'll talk a bit about
these before we actually
start using Spring Native.
Currently, the project is
in an experimental phase
and is separate from the
main Spring and Spring Boot
projects.
And I know that
could make you pause
when thinking about implementing
it in a larger project,
I've been there.
But Spring Native has been and
especially promising project,
which is probably
why at Spring I 2021,
it was announced that it would
be merged into Spring Boot 3.0
and have first class support.
With that announcement
in mind, I
think now is a perfect
time to take a closer
look at the project and to think
about how it can help us run
our workloads more efficiently.
OK, let's discuss compilation.
The first thing
we should discuss
are the differences between
Java standard just-in-time
compilation, and the
ahead-of-time compilation
that we'll be ending with today.
When developers run Java
C, normally a compile time,
we turn our .Java source
code into .class byte code.
These class files
can only really
be understood by the Java
virtual machine itself,
so before our code can actually
be executed on our server
at runtime, the JVM must
interpret or further compile it
into native code
just in time for it
to be executed at runtime.
This approach has one big
advantage and one big drawback.
On the one hand, we get to
write our code once and run it
everywhere, the
popular Java tag line,
and that gives us
portability because we
know that the JVM
will figure out
how to execute it
on whichever system
we end up deploying it to.
On the other hand, the
interpretation step
is quite expensive when compared
to just running native code
directly.
As a result, we often end
up trading performance
for portability,
even in situations
where that portability
doesn't buy us all that much.
Ahead-of-time compilation
takes the opposite approach
by compiling all reachable
code into a native executable
at compile time so
that we can simply run
our code on the target machine.
The result here is a trade
off in the opposite direction,
giving up portability in
exchange for a smaller
application that executes
our code directly at runtime
without the need for
further compilation,
meaning that your app can start
up faster and uses less memory.
Of course, each approach can
shine in their own use cases.
The standard JVM is
very well optimized
for long-running processes,
while AOT compilation
is great for
short-lived workloads
where a fast startup
time is important.
As a fun fact, AOT
compilation was introduced
as an experimental
feature in JDK 9,
though its implementation
was expensive to maintain,
and it never quite caught
on, so it was quietly
removed in Java 17 in
favor of developers
just using GraalVM,
which is what
Spring Native makes use of.
Speaking of GraalVM,
what exactly is it?
GraalVM is a highly-optimized,
open source JDK distribution
that boasts extremely
fast startup times,
AOT native compilation,
and polyglot capabilities
that allow developers to
mix multiple languages
into a single application.
Graal is an active
development with lots
of notable milestones, but the
one I'll quickly highlight here
is Java 17 support,
which is pretty recent,
having only happened
on January 18, 2022.
So to be a little bit more
specific with our earlier
Spring Native
definition, Spring Native
enables the use of GraalVM's
native image compiler
to turn Spring applications
into native executables.
This process involves
performing a static analysis
of your application
at compile time
to find all methods
and configuration
in your application that are
reachable from the entry point.
This essentially creates
a closed-world conception
of your application,
where all code
is assumed to be
known at compile time
and no new code is allowed
to be loaded at runtime.
It's important to note that
native image generation is
a memory intensive process that
takes longer than compiling
a regular application
and imposes limitations
on certain aspects of Java.
In some cases, no
actual code changes
are required for an application
to work with Spring Native.
However, there are some things
like dynamic class loading
or dynamic proxies that need
to be enumerated or configured
ahead of time in order to work.
In those situations,
Spring Native
provides things
like native hints
to simplify the process,
which are well documented.
All right.
With all that
background covered,
we can finally write some code.
Before we start
implementing Spring Native,
we'll need to create and
deploy an app to establish
a performance baseline
that we can compare
to the native version later.
Today, we'll be going through
this on the Cloud Shell,
on a new Google Cloud
project to minimize
the configuration required,
but you can follow along
on your own machine as well.
We'll start by getting our
app from start.spring.io.
The starter app uses
Spring Boot 2.6.4,
which is the latest
version that's
supported by the Spring Native
project at time of writing.
Note that since the
release of GraalVM 21.0.3,
you could use Java 17
for the sample as well.
We will be sticking
with Java 11 today
to minimize the config
involved though.
Once we have our zip
on the command line,
we can create a
sub-directory for our project
and unzip the folder in there.
Once we have the project
opened in our IDE of choice,
I'll be using
Cloud editor, we'll
quickly add a sign
of life and something
to showcase the Spring Native
performance once we run it.
One quick tip for
others using Cloud Code,
I find that I get better
code completion and import
suggestions when I
first opened my source
directory as a Workspace.
All we're doing here is
adding two fields, start time
and ready time, to help
us understand the startup
time once we run our
application, instructing
the main function to
save the start time,
then using the application
ready event to log when Spring
says our application is ready.
Once we have those
two times, we're
ready to take the
duration between them
and display the startup time
when a user visits our app.
At this point, our baseline
app is ready to go.
So feel free to build an
image and run it locally
in order to get an idea
of the startup time
before we convert it to
a native application.
To build our image, we can run
the Spring Boot Build-Image
Maven Goal.
Once that's built,
you can also use
something like Dive
or Docker images demo
to get an idea of the size
of the baseline image.
And if we want to run our
locally-built regular Docker
image, we can do
so at Docker Run.
Now that we have our
app, we'll deploy it
and take note of the
startup times, which
will compare to our native
app startup times later on.
Depending on the type of
application you're building,
there are several options
for hosting your stuff.
However, since our example is
a very simple, straightforward
web application, we can
keep things really simple
and just rely on Cloud Run.
If you're following along
on your own machine,
make sure to have the gcloud
CLI tool installed an updated.
Since this project is still
in the experimental phase,
we'll have to
configure our app to be
able to find experimental
artifacts, which are not
available in Maven
Central Repository.
This will involve making changes
to our palm, which you can do
in the editor of your choice.
Next, we'll need to bring
in the dependencies required
to run a Spring application
as a native image.
Note that this step
is not necessary
if you're using Gradle.
Now, we'll add the
ahead of time plugin
to improve native image
compatibility and artifact
footprint.
And now, we'll update
Spring Boot Mavin plug-in
to enable native image support
and use the Marketo builder
to build our native image.
Note that the tiny builder image
is just one of several options.
It's a good choice
for our use case
because it has very few extra
libraries and utilities,
which helps us to minimize
our attack surface.
But if, for example,
you were building
an app that needed access
to some common C libraries
or you weren't yet sure of
your app's requirements,
then the full builder
might be a better fit.
Now, that our apps
are configured,
we should be able
to build our image
and run our native compiled app.
Before running the build,
here are a few things
to keep in mind.
This will take more time
than a regular build.
Think a few minutes.
This build process can
take a lot of memory.
Think a few gigabytes.
This build process requires the
Docker daemon to be reachable.
And while in this example,
we're going through the process
to manually build,
you can also configure
you build phases to
automatically trigger
a native build profile.
With that in mind,
just like before,
we can build our app with the
Spring Boot Build-Image Goal.
And once that's built, we
can run it the same way.
At this point, we're
in a great position
to see both sides of the
native application equation.
We've given up a bit of
time and extra memory usage
at compile time,
but in exchange, we
get an application that can
start up far more quickly
and consume significantly
less memory,
depending on the workload.
If we run something like
Dive or Docker Images Demo
to compare the size of the
native image to the original,
we can see a dramatic
reduction in the image's size.
We should also note that
in more complex use cases,
there are additional
modifications needed
to inform the AOT
compiler of what
your app will do at runtime.
For that reason, certain
predictable workloads,
like batch jobs may be very well
suited to this, while others
could be a bigger lift.
In order to deploy
our app to cloud run,
we'll need to get
our native image
into an image store or package
manager like artifact registry.
We can get started on this
by creating a repository,
then we'll need to
make sure that we're
authenticated to push
images to our new registry.
The gcloud CLI simplifies
this process quite a bit.
Now, we'll tag our image.
Finally, we can use
Docker Push to send it
to artifact registry.
We are now ready to take
the native application
image that we've stored
in artifact registry
and deploy it to Cloud Run.
Since we've built and deployed
our app as a native image,
we can rest assured
that our application is
making excellent use of
our infrastructure costs
as it runs.
And now that our native
service is ready,
we can compare it's startup
time to the original.
Congratulations on
building and deploying
a Spring Native application
on Google Cloud.
Hopefully, this
tutorial encourages
you to get more familiar with
the Spring Native project,
and keep it in mind should it
meet your needs in the future.
Whether you created a new Google
Cloud project for this workshop
or are reusing an
existing one, take care
to avoid unnecessary charges
from the resources we made use
of.